Florida's governor says the destruction
from Hurricane Emma is horrible video
from the air shows the scale of the
damage after the giant storm ripped
through Florida millions of people who
evacuated are starting to go home
crews are bringing aid but the recovery
effort will takes weeks or even months
the storm is blamed for at least 10
deaths in Florida Georgia and South
Carolina nearly five point seven million
Florida utility customers are still
without power look at this
before-and-after images from space show
how much of the state was left in the
dark 95,000 Floridians are still living
in shelters and 10,000 people who wrote
up the storm and the Florida Keys may
need to be evacuated and after moving
through Florida the remains of armed are
bringing more rain to the southeast and
heading toward the Ohio Valley serious
damages reported as far as way as
Charleston South Carolina Jeff Glor is
in Clearwater Florida at the Coast
Guard's largest air station in the lower
48 Jeff good morning Gail good morning
to you and typically what they'll do
here in Clearwater if a bad storm is
coming through is they'll take all the
Coast Guard Jayhawk helicopters out of
here move them to a different part of
the state that is Key West or
Jacksonville or Miami this time because
this was a statewide event they had to
move all these jocks to New Orleans they
are all back now as you can see ready to
respond to calls after this storm or the
next one this really was a statewide
event that has now moved well beyond
Florida from the air
Irma's destruction along the Florida
Keys can be overwhelming homes became
piles of mangled lumber the Hurricanes
were a massive hole into the side of
this building in Orlando and in Miami
irma peeled off part of the retractable
roof at Marlins Park also wrecking
dozens of boats Miami Beach police said
it's still not safe to return a whole
lot of downed power lines flooding
trees and dangerous shape and conditions
and everyone's very very tired so that
formula can lead to some real problem 80
miles south Governor Rick Scott toured
the Florida Keys and the Gulf Coast from
the air he's activated all 7,000 members
of the Florida National Guard just
because the storm passed is not safe
we're gonna rescue everybody we're gonna
try give everybody back to normal as
fast as possible but everybody's got to
be patient
Jacksonville suffered some of the worst
flooding after nearly 10 inches of rain
as did Naples hundreds of miles south we
flew in a helicopter east of Tampa and
so how the storm transformed farmland
into swampland the I would truck the
equivalent of seven seven inches per
hour I think everything's intact oh my
god people in southwestern Florida like
Jeff Pompeo of Naples took her Mo's
strongest punch which included 140 mile
an hour wind gusts he knows despite the
damage in his neighborhood and around
Collier County the destruction could
have been worse how do you prepare for
something like this you don't know till
it's over you know what I mean we're
pretty lucky this air station here
already sent one c-130 down to the keys
to monitor communications and see if
anyone needs rescue or help they're
sending two more c-130s as we speak Gail
alright thank you very much Jeff